live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice I'm Dave Ramsey your
host Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author host a co-host of the smart money
happy hour and Ramsey personality and my
daughter is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Jamie is with
us Jamie is in Springfield Illinois hi
Jamie how are you
hi Dave thanks for having me
um I wanted to ask you and Rachel today
I've been following the Ramsay way for
several years now and I am on baby step
seven I'm 100 debt free as far as
student loans credit cards I even paid
off my mortgage a couple years ago way
to go a couple months ago a couple
months ago sorry
um I have my emergency fund I'm saving
for retirement but where I'm just really
kind of struggling and I'm afraid I
guess a little bit because I'm not
budgeting well and so I'm afraid to like
just spend freely and not I'm just not
doing budgeting very well and I guess
that's what I want your information or
you know your knowledge or advice on
Jamie what's causing you not to do you
think what's the what's what's the
reason behind not budgeting well would
you say
I honestly haven't I've never done it
well
um I think the
um gazelle intends to pay off all the
things helped me to get there and now
here I am I'm like okay I'm making more
I have a side Hustle but I don't have
anything that I have to pay so I think
there was always that like you know the
urgency is gone basically yeah and now
I'm like okay now what yeah totally well
I think one thing that you said that for
me because I'm more of a natural spender
and all of it so my natural bent is not
towards budgeting and everything so what
you're saying I'm like I totally get it
uh but what I have found is that and you
you touched on earlier so I want to just
say your words back to you that you
don't feel the freedom to spend and so
for me that is what I have found so
great about budgeting is it allows me to
be able to spend and not second-guess
myself or not think about it so I mean I
can tell you Jamie my husband I were in
baby step seven I mean we've been doing
this for 12 years and I our budget I
mean we just did April and I'm like it's
it's so consistent there may be like
four or five categories that we change
month to month but for the most part we
know what we spend and for us it's it
has become so simple because it's been
so consistent we're not in this flux of
stuff right like especially if you're on
baby steps one through three there's so
much of like oh my gosh where can we
squeeze out where can we look but maybe
step seven you can kind of relax in that
and I think that makes almost budgeting
can be a little bit easier because uh
again those budgets are so much more
consistent month to month so I would be
curious if you really did buckle down
and do every dollar Plus for just three
months I bet by the end of the summer
you're like okay this isn't as strenuous
or as hard as I was thinking uh and we
talk about two in baby step seven that
you know you you can up your lifestyle a
certain percentage you after giving a
certain percentage and all of that again
it's a little bit more LAX because like
you said you're not having to be as
focused and as as intense with every
single penny so when you say you're not
budgeting pennies or do you mean you're
not functional like tactically doing the
budget well
pension penny
[Music]
pennies
at your stage we're not we don't tell
you to pinch pennies at your stage all I
want you just to do is to do it on
purpose
and the writing it down makes you do it
on purpose and to that end
um like what is something that a
category give me a category you enjoy
spending on enjoy freedom in
sure I mean close travel what vacations
vacations okay all right see to me if
you say this is what we're going to
spend on a vacation this is what we're
going to put aside for a vacation and
then when I get ready to do the vacation
the money is laying there because I put
it in there
um that's easier and the vacation is
more relaxing and more fun than not
knowing if I screwed something else up
by going on vacation
yeah yeah that makes sense that's what
Rachel's saying there's freedom in the
plan because it you know like if for
instance if it was clothing and you went
and bought something in clothing and
there was Zero guilt because it was in
the clothing budget you know I mean
that's what it's supposed to be used for
for God's sakes and so you can relax and
enjoy the clothing purchase that way
um
and uh you know then you're not outside
you're not out of bounds and you just
the the feeling of knowing you're you're
not messing up things when you buy
something because there's a latent guilt
with buying the wrong thing in the wrong
time that puts you into a mess and you
want to that's a good guilt because it
keeps you from doing stupid butt stuff
right but you're it takes away the fear
that you're doing something stupid but
if you've got a written game plan where
everything's assigned and so I think the
freedom is what I would reach for that
Rachel's talking about
okay just a mindset change yeah it's
going to give me by doing the my my
payoff for sitting down and spending
that one hour and later spending 30
minutes because it doesn't take 30
minutes to do it once you kind of got a
rhythm going but you know and really
getting good at it the freedom the
payoff for that one hour is freedom I
can without guilt without hesitation go
out to eat because I got that go out to
eat budget right right and I don't have
to go well we kind of blew it when you
went out to eat again you don't have to
have that latent thing hanging over your
head and I I just think that's a that
you know uh we used to call it before
Rachel kind of
took it and said you know this this is
It's freedom to spend it's but we just
used to call we said okay we're not
going to call it a budge anymore we're
gonna call it a spending plan yeah
yeah because that's what it is
what you do with your money as long as
you do it on purpose because people
seldom to stupid butt stuff on purpose
let's sit down let's see if we can do a
stupid butt thing right now nobody does
that
but it's like we just keep driving
driving oh the car's out of gas who knew
yeah you know and I think Jamie the
encouragement thing where you are
because you have been so diligent with
your money you have worked hard a lot of
room and paid off debt I mean yeah you
you have the margin or you should I mean
have have the margin to be able to say
hey we're going to just do big
categories within the budget and not
every single one I think the further
back you are on the baby steps the even
more detailed you know what the
meticulous you need to be and then as
you start moving it's like oh you can
kind of make these bigger wider
categories and live within those and
it's still okay but you're still doing
it on purpose yeah let me give you an
example of that for the rest of you out
there not for her
when you first start doing your budget
you should have a separate restaurants
envelope from your grocery store
envelope
you should have a separate category
restaurant should be a separate category
you shouldn't just say food
because if you just say food when you're
first starting you'll eat out and you
won't have any money to go to the
grocery store yeah you know but when you
separate those two but then later on
when you you know you've gotten under
control you've gotten rid of the debt
you've got the margin then you could
just have food you know it's funny
though about me I'm like I should like
retake my know yourself know your money
because I even might be more of a nerd
than I realize because even though we're
on baby step seven and we've been again
doing this we're not perfect at it but
it's been over a decade I still like
more individual categories because I
just want I just want to like you like
the clarity I like the clarity of just
the complete like I have a date that's
not motivated by nerdism though that's
motivated by the free spending I know
like we have a freedom date date nights
in our food category so it's like it's a
separate yeah because I'm like I want to
enjoy our time you want to go out to eat
on date night okay I got you all of it I
don't know we're so specific on ours but
that's then you can do it without guilt
that's what you like what I like about
it yeah I like it it's a freedom there's
a freedom to it and that's where
budgeting is not a punishing process
it's a spending plan this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America open phone's
a triple eight eight two five five two
two five our question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services if you're moving you have
a long list of to-do's but neighborly's
got the local Pros like house Master The
Grounds Guys five-star painting and Junk
King there you go to check items off
that list now in other words
neighborly's got somebody to help you
with just about anything around the
house you need getting rid of mosquitoes
Molly Maid Mr Electric Mr Rooter all
those things fall under the neighborly
heading and that's why we're so excited
to have them sponsor here visit
neighborly.com today to schedule Home
Service Experts near you and today's
question comes from Mark in Wisconsin in
the current economy what is a reasonable
expectation patient as far as where home
loan rates will end up by the end of the
year is the three percent rate possible
again or do you think it'll stay where
it's at and looking at my numbers it's
depressing how much I will how much my
mortgage payment would be after putting
a lot of money down so I'm hoping for
some light at the end of the tunnel
you know I mean I I was listening to a
thing of I think it was like YouTube
fine or Yahoo finance or something today
and I mean they're thinking they're
going to raise the federal raise again
and May in uh May and June like so
that's the thing Mark I'm like I don't
know we don't have a crystal ball we
have we have no idea uh is three percent
rate possible by the end of the year no
probably not no not by the end of this
year no uh however we need to tell you
that uh economists and weather
forecasters are the only people that can
be wrong most of the time and keep their
jobs so when we predict that you know
it's just like who knows but um
realistically it takes it a little while
to settle back down if the markets if
the bond markets settle down If the Fed
quits screwing with it and so um you
know you've only got about you know
effectively nine months less than that
by the time we have this conversation
and all so I I no not by the end of the
year will we ever see three percent
again oh maybe I don't know
maybe probably the the thing you got to
think about is this
um
in nineteen
78 I got my real estate license rates
went from nine and three quarters to ten
that September for the first time ever
we saw double digit interest rates
they didn't settle back down below 10
they went all the way up to 18. in 1982.
under Jimmy Carter
and then they came back down and in the
80s I I don't remember when they came
back down below 10 but it was probably a
decade before they came back around
below 10 and honestly having I was a
young real estate agent at that time and
having lived through it going up up up
up up up up and then it came down from
18 to 14 to 12 even to 11.
when I went on the radio in 19 oh I know
wait a minute I know it took more than
decade because I went on the radio in
1992 and uh they had not gone below 10
and I was telling people you'll never
see it below 10 again and I said that on
the radio and it was completely
obviously I was completely wrong right
and it went below 10 and it stayed in
the in the five six range for a long
long time yeah 2008 crash
drove the rates down below three and
they stayed in the three and Below three
until just the other day yeah until just
about about a year ago so uh the point
being that there's a large percentage
of the history of single-family homes
prospering
in the United States that the rate was
much higher than three percent
six percent nine percent even 11 or 12
percent
and the market moved the market
continued to move uh the the only
difference was they didn't have three to
compare it to yeah
yeah I mean you got three to compare it
to it you've known yeah one especially
for the millennials
that are the ones that are probably in
the major you know yeah housing to buy
yeah 2008. yes so I mean I think and
what I would say too Mark is when it
comes to buying your home we always say
buy home when it's good for you
regardless of what the Market's doing so
regardless of whether the you know the
stock market is like going crazy or it's
down or whatever for the most part if
you have the money and you have the
ability to buy a home
that then then you have the ability to
buy a home and if it goes back down you
can refinance I mean you can always
still get a better interest rates but uh
but it is depressing I get it I mean you
know I get it two points to go with my
little story of perception there okay oh
is the history less on still going the
history
the point for the history lesson and
then I'll land the freaking plane but
the uh the circle you're just circling
okay that's great ten percent if you
were at 10 18 months ago and it had come
down to six
six would not be depressing
it's not the sixth it's depressing it's
the change from three yeah that's what's
depressing and because you saw what you
used to could have had okay and that's
what throws you off so if you bought a
house at six you're not going to die
from it and go ahead and be pissed off
and get the stupid thing paid off ASAP
and then because my interest rate on my
home is precisely zero because I don't
borrow money
so there's that and you can save up and
pay cash for a house too that's a weird
idea oh that's a really weird idea but
people do it and uh it's not that
unusual it's not as unusual as some of
you think it is so well you know don't
tell me that because I've seen it I've
been doing this for 30 years I see a lot
of people pay cash for a house so just
start going okay I'm gonna say 50 Grand
a year I'm gonna do that for five years
I'm gonna have 250k and I'm gonna buy my
first starter house well you couldn't
get to I know wherever you are I get it
but
the average house price in America's
today is about 300 so you know let's
talk about how you get 300K together or
let's talk about putting a huge down
payment and then getting it paid off as
soon as possible so you don't have to be
pissed off or depressed or whatever
emotion it is associated with it so yeah
perception is part of the issue the
actual mass part of the issue and then
it just get you know turn it as a
positive and as a motivator to push you
on out of debt Cherie is with us in
Philadelphia hi Cherie how are you
how do you go both I'm so excited I love
your whole team thank you thank you so
much how can we help
good job and so is my husband he was
recently laid off
um we our question is what do you advise
we do with our current 401K in such a
volatile Market leave it as is or move
into something else
maybe something else
something
I'm very
very 1K I have it through principal and
and to move it to a Roth like as far as
the different mutual funds are available
the Roth I don't know which one would be
the best for us we were advised by two
different people
to hold off doing anything because the
market is you know it's just um
again everything is I I guess uh it's
not in the best shape okay those people
are stupid
yeah yeah let me tell you why if the
market is if the market is down and you
have your money in mutual funds and you
sell those mutual funds and you move
over to an IRA and you do a rollover on
your 401k which is what I'm going to
tell you to do and you buy mutual funds
while the market is down
you're sold while they're down you
bought while they're down no net loss
okay
it doesn't you don't lose money if you
sell when it's down as long as you buy
when it's down
now if you sell while it's down and you
wait until it goes back up to buy
well yeah you would lose money but why
would we tell you to do that we don't do
that this is a great time to sell and a
great time to buy as long as you do it
on the same day you know so yeah you
need to get with a smart investor Pro
and you know don't leave it at your
current employer not right so that's
that and they I don't know what they're
yeah because
luxury I mean that's it's the same pool
you're working in if you're taking it
from a 401k to an IRA right it's all
within the market so uh not leaving it
with your employer go ahead and roll it
over to a traditional IRA
so here's what here's what I'm gonna do
and let's explain to you why okay so go
to if you don't have a good advisor go
to ramsaysolutions.com and click on
smartvestor Pro and sit down with
someone that is the heart of a teacher
and here's what they'll teach you okay
that when you sell the mutual funds in
the 401K in order to roll them over to
an individual Ira traditional 401k to a
traditional IRA there's no taxes
okay
okay number one number two you're
selling growth stock mutual funds in
your old 401K you're buying new growth
stock mutual funds in the new Ira that's
your rollover
um but both are down and so you're going
to have a net net on that no problems so
no taxes no loss in the market but
you've now got an advisor in your corner
you are controlling what the money goes
into you get to speak over it your IRA
is in your control the 401K back in an
old employer is clunky and hard to deal
with and has limited options so that's
why we tell you to move it Rachel's
exactly right this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsey Way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today hey thank you
to all of you that have recently joined
us uh our ratings and our rankings and
all the different ways we measure
success on the show are all up meaning
there's more of you out there than there
was last month and a lot more than there
was the month before thank you very much
and those of you that told your friends
and neighbors to come visit
thank you and we're going to ask you
continue to do it uh there's three ways
you can help us because we do not spend
a bazillion dollars we don't spend 300
million dollars a year on uh marketing
like we don't have our own stadium like
so if I excuse me I'm sure I got
allergies um but the uh
you know we don't have a big football
stadium named after us so you got to
help us all right so what do you do well
you can subscribe if you're a YouTuber a
podcast follower right uh you can tell
people about the show if you're watching
it or listening to it on radio you can
tell people about it if you're a
YouTuber digital by sharing it they've
got a sharing mechanism you can send the
link out and go listen to us yeah do all
that and leave a five-star review that
helps it pushes the pushes the show
forward and some of the algorithms and
causes people to see it that might not
see it otherwise uh and you know if you
want to leave a one star review you got
the wrong show because mama said don't
do anything if don't don't say anything
if you're getting nice to say so just
you know go somewhere else if you don't
like the show but uh but leave us a five
star subscribe follow uh
share all of those things it's a big
help we really appreciate it Daniel's
with us in Huntsville Alabama hi Daniel
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave Rachel it's great to be honest
yeah good to have you how can we help
well so uh I've got kind of a conundrum
at our house
um I've accepted a new job about eight
hours away
um and I start this Monday I left my
previous job about two weeks ago so I
had a two-week period there of just kind
of being home together and getting the
house kind of set up and uh
my plan is that I'm going to be leaving
this weekend heading to the new job
using her my wife's brother who's a
spare room for a couple weeks and then
looking for a place to rent uh while
we're in uh and letting them stay here
and finish uh school year and stuff like
that but there's some apprehension uh
from my wife about about the move and uh
she's she's kind of feeling like we're
really set up well here and um not
wanting to move the kids and worried
about uh interest rates and stuff like
that for the purchase of a new home
I'm a little bit confused why didn't we
discuss all this for you took the
freaking job
I did I
it seemed like a good idea it's a good
time for that climbing for me it's a
promotion
um it's a pay raise it's a bonus
increase and it's actually moving uh
back home for us to an area that we're
from so there's lots of family around
and everything
um and the the kids are actually seem to
be pretty pretty excited about it or at
least my son who's six years old he's
excited to go be Maryland his little
cousins
um
her biggest uh what what is her number
one reason is it the kids is it interest
rates because all of this can be fixed
or does she have a life in Huntsville
that she loves and she doesn't want to
leave
uh and there's not a life in Huntsville
that that run a little bit um she likes
kids school that they go to they and we
send them to a private school here
um she's uncertain about schools in the
area that we're going to
um which but they're schools that we
went to and and came from again I don't
understand why y'all didn't discuss this
before
I think none of that has changed
you didn't take this job and half talk
to her
well no I mean like we we talked about
it I um
you know I'd try to paint the picture of
once I got the job offer so I went to
the interview and once I got the job
offer with the raise and the bonus
um of what we could do because we could
we're gonna uh we have a lot of equity
in ours I mean but she didn't raise
these concerns then
not not exactly no uh or at least she
says I I didn't listen won't listen to
him
um
knows that that's that's kind of what
I'm thinking
like you bulldozed this and now you're
paying for it
did I miss something yeah yeah no no
home Daniel oh no man okay well you got
I mean you start Monday so you're gonna
have to make some you're gonna have to
make some decisions you guys are gonna
have to have a come to Jesus meeting and
and you have to lay out I mean she needs
to lay out all of her concerns and where
she's frustrated with you if you didn't
really listen to that and own that
um you guys look at the schools do re
like like get as much information as
possible because interest rates I mean
whatever rent for a year and we just
hadn't yeah interest rates I wouldn't do
that and there's school there's schools
everywhere I understand people love
their school I love where our kids are
but if you had to move for a job there's
great schools in every city that you can
find right like I mean for the most part
yeah so all of that can be overcome my
my issue though Daniel is that that that
um the problems that she's bringing up
can be solvable but I think she's
probably thinking holy crap you just
went and did all this and I and I may
not I may not be on board
okay
yeah
um how old are you guys
uh 34 35 okay so you've been married
what 10 years
yeah actually okay
now my wife we've been married 40 years
and my wife says we've had 33 good years
of marriage
um
and she's referring to the first seven
when her voice didn't get heard that's
how I recognize this stuff so quickly
because I'm you many years ago okay and
um and and so one of the here's the
skills that Sharon and I had to learn
number one I had to slow down and listen
proverbs 31 says who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack of gain I
used to do a lot of what you did here
which is half listen half let her talk
and then I go and did what I wanted to
do
and that's what you did and so you need
to own that she also needs to own the
fact that she was being too freaking
timid
and she needs to freaking speak up
I mean she you know
she may have hate well no no you don't
know no I'm not listen you are I don't
know I wouldn't put that on her I'm
putting it on both of them communication
style sucks okay you all did not talk up
through a major life thing where both of
you were heard because she didn't speak
loud enough and you didn't shut up long
enough
and those both of the both of you got to
work on that and if you don't I mean
Sharon and I had to work on it took us a
long time and uh we're now we loudly
communicate and often so uh but the uh
you know it's a good hillbilly fight
sometimes but at least we both get heard
and I have a rule I do not move forward
on major decisions of any kind
especially financial decisions without
sharing completely looking at me and
saying okay I'm heard
I I have some concerns I've talked about
them but I think we need to go ahead I
hear what you're saying and we come to
Total agreement both having voiced our
thing and so what does he do I think you
go back and you apologize but you need
to own what you did here she needs to
own and then say okay now what do you
want to do
you want me to go in and quit the job
that I've accepted
or do you want to make the move and if
the move goes bad
and it's horrible then we can make
another move if we have to
that would actually be my suggestion is
remember that this is maybe not forever
uh it feels like to her it's absolute
and there's no going back and she's
especially since families there and
everything it's like you're about to go
plant roots is what it you know what it
kind of feels like but giving her the
Dignity of the option of like hey if
this goes bad and we're not enjoying it
and give it a year we'll come back or
we'll go another place yeah yeah
but yeah you got to own the fact you
didn't listen and change the home the
fact she didn't speak up and then you
all got to decide what you're going to
do before Monday don't wander off up
there while this is in a fog this is not
going to go well you need Clarity yeah
before you do this it's essentially
moving my suggestion would be that both
of you own your part in this horrible
communication plan you have and address
that for the future and go ahead and
take the job and I suggest she goes
along with that with the caveat that we
could leave in a year if it doesn't work
that's what I would do
so but you're gonna have to give her an
out man you didn't get you didn't listen
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Cruz Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phone's a triple eight eight
two five five two two five so uh new
product out huh well it's been out for a
little bit and it's just become it's a
it's a it's a popular one and so we have
a new color oh a limited time color of
the Rachel Cruz slim wallet the slim
version yes which is the metallic blush
which is my favorite this is the one I
personally carry uh it sounds like a
lipstick color I know well it's just
beautiful all the ladies appreciate a
good metallic yes material so the slim
wallet is great it's thirty four dollars
uh we're actually marking it down a
little bit so uh there's a little bit of
a sale and I love this wallet we have
the ritual Cruise original wallet that
has multiple dividers within it so if
you're doing the envelope system and you
need different categories that's a great
option for that but for me in this
season of life I'm just I'm traveling
I'm moving my wallet from purse to purse
I mean it's just you know three kids
everything so I'm like I needed
something smaller that I could use in
and out of a store and not have to take
my whole purse so we came up with this
idea so there's one envelope inside that
would carry at least one category you
could even maybe put two in there if you
were able to divide it and place this
for your card so insurance card license
debit card gift cards all that uh
handgun carry permit that could be in
there too
you have to have that with the blush
so it's there but the original Cruise
slim wall if you don't like metallic
blush there's other colors available
black camel champagne and it's 34 for a
limited time so this color uh we again
bought a limited quality so once they
are sold out look now the quality is the
quality is unlimited I'm sorry the
quantity yeah thank you thank you for
that correction but anyways it's great I
I love it so hopefully all you ladies
will enjoy it so you can go to
ramsaysolutions.com store to get yours
today the slim wallet the metallic blush
it's beautiful things I thought I would
never say on the radio okay and I just
did Steve is with us in New York City hi
Steve welcome to the Ramsey Show
all right Dave Mitchell thank you for
taking the call sure what's up
I have uh I inherited a uh an IRA from
my father it's about 41 I'm sorry 29 000
in it
um I was wondering if I should cash that
out and pay off a couple of loans that I
have yes
yes oh well that's a good answer you're
going to pay taxes and no penalties
if you do not cash it out you're
required to cash it out one tenth a year
for 10 years to where within 10 years
it's all out anyway
right that's the law okay and so you're
going to be moving 2 900 a year out
anyway
um and I'm gonna go and you pay the
taxes each time you do that so it's not
like you can avoid these taxes they're
coming and I would just go ahead and
pick them up and be done with the debts
uh how far does that move you through
your debt snowball
well it's it's um I have
um a nine thousand dollar loan that I
had taken out from my 401k I have nine
thousand dollars left on my mortgage and
I have a fourteen thousand dollar boat
log and no other debt you owe more on
your boat than your house
thank you
or not a nice house yeah I don't know no
that's nice too it's just that I've been
paying it for a long time I'm kidding
with you it's great it's just unusual
agreed yeah okay so wait a minute let's
see 18 and 14 and so what is that 32 000
makes you debt free if you got any cash
I've got about 10 000 in cash and I've
got about 500 000 in my 401k okay there
you go Steve so what I would do is cash
this out your taxes will not be due on
it until April 15th of 2024
um and so I would use a hundred percent
of the money towards this and I take
three of the 10 and be a hundred percent
debt free
I'm sorry say that again okay you got
ten thousand you need 30 and 29 so you
have 39 000 total if you cash this out
and you wait until pay your taxes until
next year of course right
right okay
um well they'll take the taxes out
immediately I believe no they'll pay 20
they're not supposed to
no that's how it works on a 401K it
should not work on that way on an
inherited IRA inherited IRA you should
pay your taxes in the following year
so um
yeah uh uh yeah that's what anyway I
would I would pay off all the debts and
have seven thousand dollars left if they
don't withhold on you
that's what will happen and then I would
immediately build that seven thousand
dollars up to three to six months of
expenses but I'd be a hundred percent
debt free
okay sounds like a plan the boat will
drive better if it doesn't have payments
I know I used to have payments on a boat
years ago yeah yeah
um what kind of boat is it toy
it's a 26 foot Sea Ray oh nice boat yeah
it is a good boat okay yeah I enjoy it I
enjoy it a lot that's my summer that's
my summer home yeah I love it yeah well
ramsays are boaters too we love the lake
and the boats and the stuff and so
dragging the kids around behind it and
all that stuff different kind of boat a
little bit not much though 26 foot Sea
Ray I mean you got 23-foot Mastercraft I
mean so not a lot different boat shop
here that's it I can't really contribute
no it's not a yacht it's a three foot
longer than your Mastercraft so anyway
that's good stuff so there we go it's a
little yeah okay nice boat good job good
job Steve congrats on being debt free
yeah way to go Peggy's in Lexington hey
Peggy what's up
hi
um well I am 65 years old retired my
husband has dementia he's had it for 12
years
uh we don't have any debt we own our
home but I'm trying to I'm in the
process of starting a trust fund
um for my children
and my understanding is I can invest
money
through the trust fund once it's
completely set up and I just wanted your
advice on on how to move forward with
all of that
why are you doing that
uh that was the advice of an attorney
who sells trust funds okay who sells
trust funds the irrevocable trust fund
yeah why
because my husband has dementia and we
don't have any long-term care insurance
and I know that's I know that's what you
would say it's too late now but and he
was 52 when he got dementia so you know
highly unusual
so anyway so he's 64. how's he how's he
doing
he is physically he's okay but mentally
he's um yeah he has had constant care
but I haven't I have him at home with me
and um I'm sorry hun it's been a long
it's been a long 12 years hasn't it yes
and we've had lots
of stuff like that so but you know we've
made it through all of that but I'm just
I didn't know what to do to prepare for
my future so I went through this area
Okay so the reason for the trust is to
keep from losing it to a nursing home
well and to just to protect the law the
way the lawyer said it is to protect
your asset from what
well the nurse I guess the nursing home
like I don't have money like
okay how much how much money have you
gone
I understand how much money do you have
honey
we have uh hold on I wrote all this
thing we have about
um 115 that's waiting to be transferred
into the trust fund and just cash
and then we have a I have a 40 000
um
cash value on a whole life he's got a 30
000 on the whole cash value on a whole
life I have
um he's got about 165 and uh
I guess it's a 401 and I've got about
110 and an IRA okay and I don't know
what you're trying to protect it from
and you don't either
and so you're doing something because
someone told you to and you don't know
what you're doing
and um so I'm going to tell you don't do
it
because you don't know what you're doing
you can't tell me why we're doing this
you're doing it because some lawyers
have to do it let me tell you they're
stupid lawyers
if he has to go to a nursing home then
our assets will be protected I'm not
sure they will in an irrevocable trust
especially if it's because they've got a
five-year look back and if you're going
to put him in a nursing home you're
probably not going to want to put him in
a Medicaid nursing home where the
government pays for it because that's
called welfare
and Welfare fraud laws are very airtight
I think you need to get a second opinion
before you make this move
I I think you're I think you're going
the wrong way I think you need to learn
some more about this and you need to get
another opinion this is the Ramsey Show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today she's also the co-host
of the smart money happy hour with one
George camel which the popularity of as
a podcast has
yea now exploded it's pretty freaking
incredible how many of you have caught
onto that thing uh they're fun they're
funny
um and they're the nice Bunch around
here but today you've got me so there
you go you guys oh papa Dave today
that's right we sip on a cocktail talk
about pop culture and money is great it
is great it's a great one yeah it's fun
and funny and and you actually um also
teach some stuff when you're in there
yeah that's what he wants us to sneak it
in there yeah you got to teach something
I'm like or we can just have some kind
of value to this we we do we do it's a
good value proposition it's worth
listening to so check it out smart money
happy hour you don't want to miss out
all right Alex is going to start off
this hour in Orlando hey Alex how are
you
hey Dave I've been a little bit better
but I'm really glad to be able to be on
this call thank you so much our pleasure
how can we help sir
um so I am basically starting over
essentially my whole life at this point
lots and lots of changes
um
uh this all started maybe I would say
probably about two years ago is when
like The Dominoes started to fall uh
basically I was with my fiance and
living with my fiance in my home and uh
my daughter
and then um we split and she left and I
was with uh taking care of my daughter
for uh for the last two years
and uh just kind of went into a little
bit of a depression and then eventually
I took a leave of absence at my job a
year later
so after that happened
um I didn't really have an income
and I ended up selling my house
I sold my house
and I got a lot of money from it it was
a good return and uh impulsively in the
loneliness I met someone and during that
time uh basically I spent essentially
all of that money
parading around with that person and and
all of it and now the money's gone so so
is that person and now I can't uh
financially take care of my kids so
she's going to be living with her mother
in a different state and I am living
with my parents now and uh I'm just
trying to start over and just seeing you
know just trying to put the pieces
together to see what the board or to go
from here
wow
sorry Alex
um how old are you
I am 36. okay
so I hear broken hearts
yours
um I hear
um
shame and regret
yep uh I kind of hear I think I hear you
kind of hitting bottom
yeah
are you have you turned back up yet or
are we still sitting at the bottom
we are uh we're still sitting at the
bottom
um it's just now hitting me uh harder
now because you know she'll you know my
kid will be leaving uh in probably a
couple months less than that probably
so uh
in a couple of months I thought you said
you couldn't take care of her
uh right so she's finishing up the
school year so I'm just scraping by just
doing odd jobs to uh you know she's got
a shelter you know she lives with me and
my my parents in in their home so she
has food and everything so she's
finishing why can't you turn your life
around enough to take care of her in two
or three months
um at this point
um
her mother is essentially wanting her
time with her at this point and because
of where I'm at you know that's
different than I can't take care of her
so she's leaving
but
I mean if that's a if that's a good
thing for your daughter for her to spend
some time with her mom and it might be
uh that's a that's an okay that's an
okay thing but that's different than
I've screwed up so badly I can't take
care of her and she's leaving I kind of
thought she was already gone the way you
first said that
right no no she's she's going to be
leaving within a couple months finishing
up the school year yeah okay what did
you used to do for a living
before I've done I've done sales my
whole life
that I have just sales experience I've
done sales what's the best year of
income you ever had
uh probably
60 to 70 000. what do you think you're
gonna make in this calendar year
and this calendar year I I don't know
I'm not employed right now and the only
reason I was stopping from getting a job
at this point is because I take my
daughter to school every day it's in
order for her to stay at her old school
it's a 40-minute drive there 40 minutes
back so I've just been doing a job like
instacart and things like that just to
make ends meet in the meantime until she
leaves So the plan is to get the actual
job once she she leaves
hmm
um so Alex the the the positives here in
the stories I think that there is
something that really happens to people
emotionally when they hit that bottom
um
because I think it does allow you to
look up and say oh my gosh I here's
where I'm at and here's where I don't
want to be because sometimes when you
just live in this Perpetual cycle of
like things are kind of working it's
fine uh you just continue to live almost
in this like you know you're
sleepwalking through life almost and
then when something these drastic things
start to hit it wakes you up and so for
you in this time since you said I'm
still feel like I'm at the bottom I feel
like you just need some wins and you're
called a you know a money show we talk
more about life here on the show but
from the money perspective Alex I would
love for you to have some level of
confidence and dignity in what you're
doing and how you're handling your money
to at least get some level of a
foundation under you to stand on so that
in 90 days when you do decide okay I'm
gonna go out into the job market which
it's a great job market right now
there's a lot of open jobs so that's
another positive uh in the story but to
have some of these quick wins of
intentionality and so if you hang on the
line Austin's going to pick up and we'll
give you every dollar Plus
and Financial Peace University because I
want you to have something that you can
control in your life right now because
there's a lot out of your control is
what it feels like I want you to map out
what kind of man you want to be
one year from now and three years from
now in your spiritual walk your physical
condition
your finances in your career
and then I want you to start taking the
steps to be that man immediately
immediately you figured out who you
don't want to be now you figure you need
to figure out who you do want to be and
I would figure out Alex too to to throw
a Dr John deloney you know Spice in here
is I mean if there's a if there's a
great counselor therapist Pastor someone
to sit down and really understand Alex
what caused me in the first place to be
making these decisions because you can
just White Knuckle your way through good
decisions in life but when you
understand underneath what those
motivators are what are those things in
your life and in your story that have
caused that that's gonna that's gonna
help you too so I mean honestly I would
sit down with someone and agree with
Rachel and I would also find a great
church get some good men around you that
are who you want to be in your next
stage and start looking at them and
saying how do they function how do they
how are they a Dad how are they in a
relationship how do they do their career
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you're
wondering whether to buy or sell a home
this year here's what you need to know
about the housing market
there's still more buyers than there are
homes for sale
there's still more demand than there is
Supply so we're not going to see prices
plummet
interest rate hikes have made mortgages
uncomfortable
unaffordable piss you off I get it
home prices aren't going to spike either
they're going up but very gradually like
they have in most years prior to the
weirdness we just went through if you're
buying a home you may still face some
competition
you may see some big price tags if you
want to sell your home chances are you
can still make a good profit and you can
sell it you're just going to get it
ready and you're going to have a normal
marketing period 90 to 120 days you're
probably not going to get 100 of asking
price but that's a fairly normal
transaction in real estate
and that's the world we live in now so
if you want to have all of this happen
properly you need an incredible agent in
your corner and you can find these
they're Ramsey trusted through our
endorsed local providers program
top performing high octane high protein
agents around the country that we trust
to serve you well and get to get the job
done in this weird time we're in
ramsesolutions.com agents how you find
them
ramseysolutions.com
agent thanks for hanging out with us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five alley is in
Denver hey Allie welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave and Rachel thank you guys so
much for taking my call it's an honor to
see good deal you too what's up
all right so my question today is on
paying off our mortgage versus investing
a full 15 so some background on our
situation
my husband and I are both 25 years old
we're debt free besides the house we
have a household income of about 250 of
that and about 180. my contribution
our mortgage is 400 000
um but it's always been a dream of mine
to be a stay-at-home mom we're not
having kids yet but I see it in the next
like three or four years and so what are
you doing what your advice would be I
work in sales wow you're good at it you
make 180 he makes he makes 70.
yeah they're about and I mean
I get closer to like 280 this year too
it's combined
oh no I know I was like dang girl wow no
no no no no no but still but still
that's 30. that's thirty thousand
dollars more so that's that's not bad
yeah okay and so you you want to set up
to be able to quit when you have kids in
the next few years
yeah it's very cool this has kind of
been
key to value in it yeah and I am still
kind of like not entirely sure my whole
life I've thought I wanted to stay at
home and then this job has come up and
I've really enjoyed it it's been fun
I've been good at it and I'm not sure if
I'll want to stay home but at the same
time like I just want the freedom of the
choice when we get to that point you
know
um so just kind of trying to set
ourselves up to have the option if we
want it so so what's your question then
yeah so do you think right now we are
paying around we are investing around
like 10 mostly because my commissions
have been increasing recently so that's
part of why explodes into 15 prior to
that we were doing the 15.
um but we've been putting like
everything at the house every month we
possibly can and so I'm just wondering
like if you would suggest that we
continue with the 15 even with the ideas
we potentially leaving the workforce in
the next couple years and then us losing
that income
or if we should put like more
aggressively for the next just couple
years how long have you been paying
extra on the house
a couple months now we only got the
house in November yeah okay how much did
you pay for the last two months on the
house
extra about three grand extra three
thousand dollars
yeah in the coming months we're looking
at like six to eight extra moving
forward because we we got a car
um that was something else we how much
do you have left on the house Ally 400
it was a 400 000 houses is it still 400
yes give them okay that's what's
remaining on it that's what's remaining
okay
okay eight grand a month I like that's a
hundred thousand out of three hundred
thousand
okay right that's very doable uh and
that puts you out of debt in four years
uh now yeah I would continue to do that
and while putting 15 of your income into
retirement I don't no I would not back
off on retirement because here's the
thing 10 of 300 000 is thirty thousand
dollars thirty thousand dollars a year
does not solve this problem
it doesn't solve a four hundred thousand
dollar problem a hundred thousand
dollars a year does
but Thirty dozen
okay so okay uh you you've got a a
philosophical thing more than a
mathematical thing going here so the the
actual math associated with what you're
requesting so if you stopped retirement
would you pay off the house that much
faster about six months faster is all
yeah and an extreme example you know
it's still yeah so the difference in 10
15 doesn't matter for your goal yeah of
knocking out the 400 what what matters
on your goal and knocking out the 400 is
the eight grand a month going on it or
more right and just leaning in and
making that like one of your sales goals
it's a reason I'll go make a sale at the
end of the day when I'm a little tired
and didn't really want to go make that
last call I'm gonna go make it because
I'm Gonna Knock the house out that much
faster uh because I got to tell you when
I'm a salesperson and when you can
increase your income by extra effort the
way you can and the way you obviously
have you're obviously very good at it
congratulations yeah and Ali if you guys
do this for two three years you'll be
out of debt you'll be out of debt and
you don't know even with Family Planning
I mean everyone's story is so different
it's down that road you know you could
get pregnant the first month it could
take you guys another five years or you
don't mean you may end up adopting like
you you never no and so I love people
that prepare before the family you know
begins where they're like okay I want to
be looking out because I know we're
going to take this step eventually but
it may not even be in your timeline and
if you guys are aggressive in two to
three years you're gonna basically have
it paid off so even if you did have a
baby and stayed home you're only gonna
have another year or two of the mortgage
if you go down to his salary so if
you're aggressive now you'll have plenty
of room whether you get pregnant right
away if that's what you guys want here
in two to three years or not you'll have
the ability to to be home and I think
that's a great financial goal for you
um I think it's awesome yeah I think you
got good goals and you're obviously High
Achievers so yeah but let's let's recap
the answer to your question is put 15 of
your income into retirement and
everything else you can find throw it at
the house so that you can hit this goal
the more fired up you are about having
that house paid off the faster it's
going to be paid off now we say be
intentional not necessarily necessarily
gazelle intents and these last four five
six baby steps uh and uh but if you want
to you know be intense because you have
this goal of knocking it out and to have
the dates line up with when you want to
be home then I'm in with that yeah I'm
good for that open phones are triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Tom is in Long Beach hey Tom how can we
help
David is a pleasure to talk with you
I've been just dying to talk with you
for for so long and have a quick burning
question I just want to want to find out
what your take is I think I know what
you're going to say but okay what's your
question I want to ask you
uh well I'm interested and my wife and I
are interested in buying a second home
and
um we want it as a kind of a vacation
home right so I can do my woodworking
how much is it and um
uh well uh we're just shopping right now
so I mean what do you want to spend on
it for something
I guess probably under 300. have you got
the money you know
we don't well that's what I'm calling it
out I want to ask you I mean do you have
300K to put on the house
no then you can't buy it
right no I get I get you yeah
I'm seeing every day you know I see
every day that the the prices go up I
don't care in this area a second house
is a toy we pay cash for toys
if you can't pay cash for it you don't
buy a mountain house or lake house or a
woodworking house or whatever this is
It's a toy you knew I was going to say
that too but I'm here to say what you
always predict I'm going to say that's
what I do every day over and over and
over and over again this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
oh
we know there's a bunch of you out there
that are new to this Ramsey stuff we
know that because our rankings and
ratings have gone up dramatically and so
if you're brand new and some of the
stuff we say is um
well it's uh kind of sounds like inside
baseball like it's Tribal speak and you
don't know what all the words in the
vernacular means well uh it's like baby
steps and uh death snowballs and all
that kind of stuff well uh we'll help
you jump in okay just go to
ramsesolutions.com click on the get
started button it's a completely free
thing it'll just walk you through where
you are and what your next step is and
you'll begin to kind of get the vibe of
what we're doing the process here and uh
we'll walk you through it again
completely free
ramsaysolutions.com click get started
Cole is in Wichita Kansas hey Cole
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave
I'm proud to be on here with you I think
uh for your time honored to have you how
can we help
well you messed up so
um
we are in the hole big time I mean I
guess not big time we're on our way
there
um and I don't know
what to attack first I guess
um what we're going to do we're selling
one of the vehicles
um it's it's got some problems that are
coming to arise that I've noticed and uh
so we're just going to sell that one
um
whatever money we have left over we're
gonna save a thousand of it for our
emergency fund
and
then start applying whatever else we
have to the rest
basically what I don't know what to do
is like looking ahead to the end of this
month
um
I'm gonna be in the red and I don't know
what not to pay and still be able to
live I guess okay
um I don't want to go behind on anything
but I it it's inevitable at this point
I'm pretty sure okay all right
how old are you guys
uh I'm 31 my wife is 30. how long you
been married
uh Five Years on Friday what's your
household income
uh see that'd be uh 100 and 112 000.
okay so you make good money
yeah I mean hundred thousands no no
slouch in Wichita Kansas dude
that's excellent yeah so what's causing
the problems
well we I think where we're at right now
is
um after Christmas uh there are some
bills that I forgot about and uh let's
go ahead and uh an almost one year old
and uh the hospital called on that and I
y'all understand that playing with them
and that payment plan came out and it
overdrafted my account
and after that I'm just
trying to play catch-up I guess on that
and it's just been one thing after
another
um the entire Tire blowout on one of the
vehicles and get a new tire for that and
you know there's expensive right now
um how much was the hospital bill that
came out of your account
uh that one was a it's only it was a 223
220 payment was making 115 000 a year
222 does not put you in this mess
what
else do you have uh so so
um the we have two vehicles right now
um one of them we owe 4 500 on the other
one with a 6200 on okay um the 6200 one
is the one we're selling by the way okay
um we've got uh my wife has around 30
000 in student loan
um the uh credit cards
um is right around fourteen thousand
um
in the house is a hundred and two
thousand
and what else is there
how much is the house worth
uh how's the right now I haven't had an
appraised or anything but I'm I'm
thinking that I could get around 140 to
100. so your house payment's not like
insane it's not like you guys live in a
half a million dollar million dollar
house
um right it's a thousands fifty dollars
a month yeah
so Cole I mean you know
yes I understand this is it's
overwhelming and there's a lot of
numbers here but also
um
this could work so my question is month
to month do you guys are you is your
lifestyle just completely out of control
are you guys just spending a ton
um no without no you got a lot of money
going somewhere that you haven't shown
us yet
yeah oh daycare too so 300 a week going
to daycare what's your wife make a year
uh she makes sick EQ okay was that part
of the 112.
yeah that's part of it yeah I make I
make 62 she makes 52. okay okay the only
thing I can think of is
um you're completely chaotic and
disorganized to the point that you're
out of control yeah
that's the only explanation because
there's nothing there's nothing glaring
in these numbers I kept waiting for the
fifty thousand dollar car
and it wasn't here
I kept waiting for something big that
was smacking these smacking this budget
in the mouth and it's not here so the
only thing I can come up with is you
guys must be some of the most
disorganized completely chaotic people
that I've run into in a while
yes I would agree with that that's right
we're jumping on with this we want to
get it you know that's fair I'm not
picking that's not I'm just trying to
help you trying to figure out where this
is going so I know how to fix it I'm not
picking on you okay because I'm I'm I I
get that so here okay that's bad news
and that's good news the good news is
that you're the problem the bad news is
you're the problem so we can fix this
okay really quickly
so a detailed in-depth game plan where
you tell every dollar exactly what to do
every single month and you and your wife
pinky swear and spit shake that you're
not doing a freaking thing with a single
penny except what you agree to on this
hardcore plan
we'll get you out of this really fast
you're going to turn around so fast and
call that plan is you're not you're not
going out to eat you guys aren't
amazoning stuff to the house you're not
shot like you're doing you're literally
doing off Amazon Prime you're doing
nothing but catching up in these bills
because they're not going out to eat you
can do this call I mean the numbers are
here then I'm like no vacation this
summer you're broke people
yep no eating out you're broke people
you don't see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there as your
extra job to clean this freaking mess up
okay so this is like put yourself in
financial boot camp because here's the
thing you two are not dumb people
and if I hired you and said I'll give
you ten thousand dollars to look at
these people's budget and tell them
exactly what to do with it you'd have it
done in an hour and a half
yeah so here's what you do you take care
of food first
license water a second
pay the house payment third
you pay the car payments forth you put
gas in the car fifth you don't need any
clothes you've got enough this month yep
okay buy clothes only when there's
something that's completely about to
fall off of somebody or whatever right
now you've got people got clothes in
their closet for days I don't don't talk
to me about style you're broke people
okay and so you know this is what you do
that's what Sharon and I did all right
and so you could turn this around really
fast we call that the four walls you
take care of the Four Walls of your
house the necessities of life food
shelter clothing Transportation
utilities gas in the car and everything
else can wait yeah
well it won't have to by the way when
you start writing this out you have
enough room in this budget to probably
pull this off
I don't hear the payments because you're
not paying any making any payments on
the stupid student loan
it's not affecting anything and if you
just throw the credit card payments in
the in the trash for one month whoopee
Dumpty
oh I hurt my credit well good you don't
need credit you're not really good with
it
yep okay exactly and so if you guys and
honestly I'm like where you guys are
there's almost this like radical
Behavior change that needs to occur on a
very radical scale because you've been
on one extreme I'm like and I know you
have a one-year-old but honestly I'd say
you know between now and July do
ubereats at night for for four months
just just do make some extra like you
guys need to like not get ubereats
delivery
but like shock the system Cole you and
your wife honestly shock the system
delivery time for sure period of time
and hold on the line Austin will pick up
we'll give you guys Financial Peace
University yeah go through the Financial
Peace University honestly you you guys
got this you could do this you get that
every dollar budget out tonight you and
your wife sit down and say okay we can
eat we got the money we can do the we
keep the lights on we can keep the house
payment paid you can do all those things
and the rest of it you just got to fight
through and you can do this
foreign
[Music]
Cruise Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author my daughter is my
co-host today if you didn't know April
is National financial literacy month all
month long teachers and students in
classrooms Across America are taking
time to talk about the importance of
learning good money skills we've got one
of our incredible teachers that teaches
foundations in Personal Finance in the
classroom if you didn't know we have a
high school curriculum that's in about
48 percent of the high schools that
means there's 52 percent that need to be
doing it that aren't but this teacher is
absolutely incredible we wanted to get
her on the phone in honor of financial
literacy class it's Chelsea Chelsea is
uh in Delton Michigan Hi Chelsea how are
you hi Dave how are you good good
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you for
teaching the class of course it's a
blast I love it now what what school do
you teach at
High School okay and so what what age
kids young people are going through this
um it's mostly Juniors and seniors okay
that's good so they're kind of looking
out into the world saying we're coming
at you we need to know how to handle
this money stuff
oh yeah definitely now how many kids are
enrolled at this school
[Music]
oh wow all right that's a small
World cool yeah yeah where is Belton or
Delta is it Belton or Dalton Delton okay
yeah um it's closest to Kalamazoo oh
yeah okay all right and uh how long
you've been doing this how long you been
teaching the foundations class
this is my sixth year
okay
so what's happening actually in the
classroom that makes you want to keep
doing this while you're doing it
well uh my first year teaching I had no
idea what Ramsay was or anything so that
first year I taught it I was really
teaching myself and I thought I was good
with money but I absolutely was not I
was really good with credit card debt
and I was like I need to practice what
I'm preaching so I fully embraced the
curriculum became debt free in 2020. WoW
yep awesome and uh
I um celebrated with my students and you
know they hear all of my money stories
that I've
had throughout the process so so good
that's amazing so much fun yeah that's
amazing for your own story and then the
stories of the kids in your class have
you had through those six years ones
that have graduated and have come back
and said oh my gosh you know thank you
so much for teaching this because of X Y
and Z do you have a story in mind
or think of a student or two
yeah at um like homecoming games I'll
see previous students and I'll be like
are you still debt free and they're like
I am and uh this year I really focused
on going to college debt free
um just as I've gotten more comfortable
with the curriculum I'm like this is
going to be my goal this year and of
course we watched The Borrowed future oh
thank you and it scared my kids of
course
um
in a good way yeah good and I have so
many kids who are like student loans are
off the table they're going to community
colleges instead of universities they're
applying for scholarships just so many
kids this year are so dedicated to no
student loans so it's awesome you know
all we had to do is tell them
right nobody told them you know way to
go you're there to tell them thank you
so much now Michigan's got legislation
uh that mandates personal finance
curriculum right
yes
um actually it will be in effect for
this current Year's eighth grader
so when they graduate high school they
do have to have a financial literacy
class credit
and my amazing principal Lucas
treeweiler he is dedicated to your
curriculum to fulfill that credit for
our student so body Michigan people we
can do it for you they got to have the
credit we can help you get there we've
met all the Michigan benchmarks and uh
yeah and then the lesson plans make it
easy for you don't they yes oh my gosh
yes it's amazing yeah amazing our guys
have built this out so well our whole
Education team is are actually
phenomenal Professionals in curriculum
development to make it easy for the
teacher make it fun for the kiddos and
uh it's it's lights out amazing and you
are oh yeah lights out amazing for
teaching it and forgetting your and
jazzing up your amazing principle way to
go
thank you and the kids do love George
Campbell's dad jokes so you know
that's good listen we all love George
Campbell's dad jokes even dads Love
George Campbell's dad jokes yep so oh
man that's fun hey congratulations and
thank you so much for leading this for
so long for just being a teacher too
Chelsea I just know in today's world
it's just it's a lot and as a mom with
little ones in the school system just
thank you for all you do and all the
teachers out there because it's a it's a
it's a hard job and sadly sometimes a
thankless job so just hear thank you uh
from us and what you do so yeah I
couldn't do it and it's not because of
the kids the helicopter parents
I would do like a Sam's missile and just
take out the helicopter and it'd be over
I mean I just couldn't do it I could the
helicopters would crash because I
couldn't do it I can't handle them and
so yeah because I mean I I grew up in a
house you know in the where if if we had
an argument with the teacher my parents
automatically assumed the teacher was
right
that's where we started I had to make a
real case for yourself for myself in
other words I had to learn to argue well
if I was gonna if I otherwise just shut
up there are great parents out there
though there are great parents and there
are fabulous teachers yes that put up
with some not great parents and some not
great students and some great students
yes it's all done my own age it's all
mixed in all mixed in there all let's
say they have a very selfless
sacrificial job so teachers thank you
it's tough any teachers listening out
there we love you we respect you we
thank you and as a part of the financial
literacy month uh we want you to enter
the Ramsey teacher appreciation giveaway
sponsored by the Army National Guard no
less one teacher will win a five
thousand dollar vacation two more
teachers will win a three thousand
dollar vacation each
no purchase necessary if you're all you
have to do is be a teacher and go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher you can
enter and we want to make a be a
blessing and at least three of your
lives and to all of you just say We
Salute You thank You Chelsea you're
absolutely amazing beautiful beautiful
stuff Anthony's with us in Sacramento
Anthony how are you
good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
uh I'm just looking kind of more or less
just for like a future financial
decision
um whether it be like trying to invest
more or looking into kind of buying a
house
okay
um
so where are you at Anthony with your
with your money is is there debt do you
have anything liquid
so I have I have about 30 000 in my
savings uh debt free
uh making around 120 a year good for you
how old are you
uh 23.
amazing what do you do
I'm a firefighter good for you awesome
well done
um you know well Anthony I mean yeah the
the savings you have is is incredible
are you looking to settle down in where
you live right now like do you think
that that'll be a long-term play for you
location wise yeah I mean I mean
ultimately I would like to you know kind
of get a first house and then see from
there whether it be kind of moving up to
another house and using that one as a
rental property
um I just you know I'm I feel like I'm
kind of in a good position right now are
you in a serious relationship
yeah I live with my girlfriend
okay
all right
um don't buy a house with someone you're
not married to so if you buy a house you
buy a house
you don't buy a house with your with
your shacked up girlfriend that'll get
you in a mess okay yeah but uh now uh I
will say if you're about to get married
then she would be involved in the
purchase of the house after you're
married and so I don't know what your
timeline is on that kind of stuff but um
uh if that if that's not coming soon
don't you know you don't put her on the
deed and honestly she's not in the
decision either
right right okay but if there's gonna if
there's gonna be a uh if there's going
to be a wedding in the offing then we
change the whole dynamic and we involve
her in the purchase and you close after
you're married yes both of you are on it
so looking at a good starter home
Anthony you can use some of this money I
would keep some of it as an emergency
fund at three to six months of expenses
whatever's remaining just making sure
you have at least five percent for a
down payment if that's if that's what
you want to do uh and then start
investing 15 of your income into
retirements after that is what we would
say walking down the baby steps yeah
very good good job you're ahead of the
game at your age sir this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage in the studios it's
the Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Reginald Cruz number one best-selling
author my daughter Ramsay personality is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jackson Memphis
hey Jack how are you
hey Dave and Rachel how are y'all doing
better than we deserve what's up
I mean it's a lot of questions and
I'm kind of working a lot right now and
I just need some direction really
um I'm 18 years old and I'm trying to
pay myself through college
um I'm already planning to go to
Community College
and I don't have a car and there's just
a lot of things that my family
excuse me can't pay for got allergies
um and I was just wondering like how
should I spend the money that I get in
like in preparation for going through
college
yeah it's some great questions Jack
um
are you a senior right now in high
school
yes okay and do you have any money saved
going into next semester's tuition for
the fall
no
um I'm actually eight hundred dollars
into my emergency fund
okay that's great so you mean you have
an 800 emergency fund
yeah yeah good okay and how much will
Community College be per semester
um it's gonna be free for the first two
years oh that's great okay
um and so a car is something that you're
gonna be looking towards are you going
to be living at home while you're at
school
that's the plan yes yeah that's great so
your expenses
will be
books
um things to get you like academically
and then maybe some money for food and
gas and all of that correct
yeah just some basic expenses what do
you think you're going to be making at
these hustles
um so I just got blessed with a nice
um backpack leaf blower and I posted on
my neighborhood Facebook page and stuff
and I've got a few yards that um I'm
fixing to do
and uh I would be making about an extra
two I think so extra 200 a month
probably
okay you got blessed with a backpack
what leaf blower a leaf blower I didn't
hear that yeah that's great because rich
people are afraid of leaves okay so yeah
you can turn that into money yeah
um
foreign
okay so your side hustle is lawn care
yes sir with allergies okay I went
through the same thing that's why I'm
laughing I can remember running the weed
eater and sneezing for three days okay
the uh
well you know what you're looking at is
basic math simple math okay you want two
thousand dollar car
at 200 bucks a month it's going to take
you 10 months if 500 bucks a month
sorry sorry to interrupt but I work
part-time at Firehouse Subs and I make
about a thousand a month so I'm just
doing that as well as working part-time
Oh I thought your side hustle was your
only thing oh it's a side hustle your
main gig is Firehouse aside from going
to high school
yes sir gotcha okay so 1200 a month
yeah okay good and how much of that can
you put away towards the car
um thousand that's
I'd say I want to try and save up about
like four thousand
if you do a thousand for four months
you'd have it right
right
okay and I guess like another question
is
um
it's just like I feel like expenses they
just like come out of nowhere like for
me prom is something that I was like
planning to do
but like now I do the every dollar
budget like I'm just now seeing how this
stuff add up adds up and so I was just
wondering like how do I stay focused and
um make decisions on purchases
especially trying to save for college a
car yeah
let me just say Jack this is a great
life lesson because while prom is the
reality in your world life and other
things are the reality for other
listeners that stuff will continue to
always come up like that you are
experiencing true life with that I mean
that that is that is what happens and so
in your budget we have What's called the
miscellaneous category
so I would put that in and put some
money towards that so it's kind of your
catch-all when stuff does pop up and
you're like oh my gosh I didn't realize
I had that you can take money out of
that category so it doesn't completely
ruin your entire budget there's going to
be some stuff you have to say no to
um I don't want you to say no to prom so
I'm like yeah let's figure out a way to
get some money saved if if your if your
parents aren't available to help
um and maybe that's working a little
extra maybe that's not going out to the
big nice dinner maybe you skip one of
the things that night I don't know I
don't know how much prom tickets cost
these days but what do I know maybe
drive your own car
maybe drive your dad's car instead of
getting a limo so that's why I was
thinking about the limo thing oh and I
know I was like no it's like oh then I
said that yeah so uh it's your dad's car
that's what we used to do back in the
day when the dinosaurs roamed the Earth
but when you walk through that process
Jack what you're experiencing at 18
it's kind of the same life in a sense
obviously it's not prom that you're
going to experience at 28 38 and in your
whole life and so learning how to be
diligent was putting money away and then
prioritizing when things do come up to
say okay do I have the money or do I not
and so it's all about really at that
point making choices but Jack your
overall Financial picture you're a hard
worker
you're making 1200 bucks a month as a as
a high schooler which is amazing and
you're gonna be able to make a lot more
this summer when you don't have school
college is free you're living at home so
you're there's no expenses so as you
continue just to save so I would say
throughout Community College your goal
needs to be put as much money away as
possible because when you graduate from
school then you're going to have this
expensive transition honestly into the
real world maybe that's moving cities uh
that might be you know taking on a job
renting an apartment or a house for the
first time so having cash available for
you when you graduate college I think is
is going to be your number one goal but
expenses and stuff you should be able to
cash flow all that with working
hey guys The Building Wealth event is
going to be in Salt Lake City in less
than three weeks if you've reached your
enough is enough moment I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired uh hey
we're here to help or maybe you just
want to come hang out with the tribe the
Ramsey tribe we'd love to have you
there's a few a few tickets left will be
there April the 24th Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Jade warshaw and I we're going
to give you the proven plan to get out
of debt save money be outrageously
generous but most of all how to build
wealth in 2023 and we're ready to dive
in some of the Hot Topics everybody's
talking about like inflation and
investing and interest rates all this
stuff and get your tickets now at
ramseysolutions.com we'll also be in
Anaheim California on May the second
with Ken Coleman Dr John deloney and
Jade warshaw that event is almost sold
out there's about like 62 tickets left
so they're only 49 a piece
ramseysolutions.com
events Anaheim Salt Lake see you soon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five so joining us for a segment
here to hang out my good friend Damon
John from Shark Tank hey Damon how are
you I'm well how you doing better than I
deserve sir thank you for hanging out
with us so I got a call the other day
from Damon and he said I've got a book
that just hit number one I want to talk
about it and I got the book and I said
yes we want to talk about it it's a kids
book little Damon learns to earn now I
gotta say little Damon you were a better
looking guy when you had that hair on
top man that's pretty good I have to
cover the bald spot with one of my new
hats
I love the hat excellent okay now I read
the book little Damon learns to earn a
few minutes ago and um
it I kind of remember the story from
somewhere it looks familiar it does it
does it looks like a little demon who
learned to earn but he was probably
about 28 years old and after he earned
it
[Music]
um
he almost went bankrupt after he had 10
million dollars in the bank
a little operation called FUBU that made
you who you are right that is right but
but let's really open up but I didn't
call you initially tell you about the
book I call this hey I need some advice
Dave because uh you know I know you've
been doing this for quite some time in
this space and you really can help me
and your advice was come on Michelle man
let me let me let me let me share what
you're doing with the public man and so
I appreciate you for what you've been
already doing
um and I'm just finding out how people
don't care about politics or anything
else when it comes to the future of any
and all of our children in this great
country so this is one thing we can all
agree on Amen so number one kid
best-selling kids book little Damon
learns to earn Rachel you got to take
this home read it to the the grandkids I
know I know this is so so great okay so
what was it like for you what was like
the motivation to write the kids book
because you know you can write any kind
of book but for you writing a kids book
is that's a special thing
it is you know and I have thank God I've
been graced so and blessed with three
New York Times bestsellers for adults
and uh you know I'm always asking this
up I'm dyslexic uh it's cool and and
sometimes the adults we're all stuck in
our own ways sometimes or whatever the
case is but I have a little beautiful
new girl in my life I my oldest
daughters are 29 and 24. my idea of
teaching my oldest daughter's Financial
intelligence at the time I didn't have
much of it I said to them that you you
want a new car you go work really hard
and I'll match the money you have and
get you a new car that wasn't teaching
on financial intelligence I was teaching
them how to work hard
um and this little girl I realized uh we
have lost our national heroes after the
kids are five years old and they don't
have uh Peppa Pig to watch anymore they
don't have what we grew up on a lecture
company in Mr Rogers and and Bob or
Steve Ross whatever the name and even my
children you know Steve from Blue's
Clues so there are no national heroes
they watched a bunch of children on
other families nothing wrong with this
but they're just watching people play
with toys and unboxing and they're not
caring about making what's in the box
they want to see what's what's uh
they're making outside the box so I
wanted to come up with something where I
connect with my little girl teach her
the process and the idea of
Entrepreneurship at a very young age and
I was tired of reading books to her
about princesses and ponies and telling
her baby I promise if you wait one day
there's going to be a prince to come
grab you with a glass slipper or or uh
you know I don't know yeah find you in a
tower and you better not live with seven
dwarfs I
want her to create her own
for a slipper Factory or store
you know the teaching financial literacy
and teaching entrepreneurship are two of
the lost things for sure in our high
schools in our uh homes and some really
really proud of this book because it's
all about little Damon he goes on a
journey of learning to earn and uh and
oh by the way he didn't go work at fast
food and gripe about what they pay he
went and started a business
and that's the beautiful part right we
show there you know so so the beautiful
part about this is like you said you
read it a couple of minutes ago you can
read it like this it's for kids five to
ten years old parents and kids
connecting together you read it when you
read to a child you read it once every
month you know they want to read all the
great books once every month so it's a
way to casually engage them you know
when we tell our kids hey don't lie
remember what happened to the boy who
cried wolf well now we can say hey you
wanna you wanna earn that what did
little Damon and his crew do
um but this is what I'm going to be
calling my life Legacy it's not about
this book it's about me heading down
this journey where I want to join the
Dave Rams of the world and get other
people in other states and other
celebrities whatever to talk about this
and to bring this to our education uh
educational base and our teachers and
create this uh as uh uh you know a
mandate in schools and by the time I'm
going I want my little daughters to say
my daddy started the conversation along
with some other great people about how
we have to change this country's
trajectory and stop becoming country of
renters and a country of owners and
really have the American dream amen amen
know how to leave leave the cave kill
something and drag it home it's good
stuff so when some when you read through
this I mean as I said I've been through
it but when you wrote it when the
parents read through it with their kid
what is it your hope that they the kid
Will Come Away with
I'm hoping the kid comes away with the
fact that they have a skill or they have
something they love and that anything
that they buy they can sell anything
they do for free they can get paid for
and that learning to work within their
Community or their surroundings and the
things they actually have can be of
benefit to them and not just one person
benefits
everybody benefits simultaneously and
that is what entrepreneurship is about
and that's what I want them to take away
from it and I want their minds to open
up as they are growing up going wait a
minute
I can actually do that I can get paid
for what I love to do so you know the
school system right now is back like it
was 80 years ago they were in Industrial
Age they taught us you know how to build
ships because they taught us a trade or
how to be a great employee but today if
you know it is ideal if you don't teach
them how money works and then it's 17
years old they can acquire six to seven
hundred thousand dollar worth of student
debt that they aren't going to pay off
into their 50s well then you've created
and a country of people who learn to
live off of debt and I'm not talking
about Good debt we're talking about bad
debt amen Diamond John of Shark Tank and
FUBU Fame the new book is a children's
book little Damon so good
and uh you know one of the things I
loved about this from an entrepreneurial
standpoint is it's not just he learned
to open his own business but he hired
his friends yeah he built a leadership
team already I mean he built a
production team and was delegating and
and delegating their own stuff out to
them it was very cool it was
resourcefulness because like you said
Damon I'm like it's like just look in
your sphere and what you have around you
who's around you what's around you
what's inside of you and use all of that
for the good of your community and then
you can make money while doing that as
well so all of that you know and I was
just naturally do it nobody just puts it
in a format for them because you know
when we were growing up our Lemonade
Stand was as big as anybody who passed
the you know past the block you know the
kids Lemonade Stand today is as big as
the entire world once they push a button
on this thing so yeah we were always
doing it and our kids do it now but we
just haven't formalized and show them
that by the way there is a path to doing
this forever for yourself in your
community and having fun and making
money and creating change yeah and the
beautiful thing is you're you're helping
people and they give you as my friend
Rabbi Lapin says they give you
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces on them
that's what happened you know I'm having
so much of a blast doing this you know
uh you know I listen I'm wearing this
crazy hat and the reason why I said
where it is because the kids don't care
about my ten thousand dollar Tom Ford
suits but when I wear this hat and we
all know that children are not now
exiting their parents homes till 30s I
tell them they go hey you're going to
create Magic yeah I'm gonna show you how
to disappear out of your parents home
I'm gonna show you how to make one
dollar into three dollars that's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna show you some
magic I'll show you something it's a dad
blind magician who knew
oh well we got to spend a little time
with Damon he was down uh back in 2020
spoke for us at an entree leadership
event and then we got to have dinner at
the house a bunch of us together and
hang out had a great evening and uh it's
an honor to call your friend I'm proud
of you it's a good book little Damon
thank you learns to earn Damon John
ladies and gentlemen thanks for stopping
by my friend thank you always for the
support thank you for what you're doing
for our children and our future in this
country thank you Dee thank you
everybody
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Ty co-host of the podcast that is vastly
popular these days called smart money
happy hour she and George Campbell do
that you guys ought to check it out it's
a where culture is it beats buttermilk
no not cultured buttermilk what is it
what what pop culture current events and
money okay there we go you don't even
know about cultured buttermilk do you no
I literally have no idea what you're
saying okay that's perfect that's
exactly why I did that okay hey in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage wow Evan and Lori are with us
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve cool do you all know what
cultured buttermilk is I do you do oh
man I'm from West Texas she's from
Tennessee okay good we got half and half
we're running a 50 here on the cultured
buttermilk important people want to know
these things hey guys so what part of
West Texas where are you from well we
live in Dallas now near Dallas okay how
much debt did you pay off 145
000 very cool how long did that take 27
months all right and your range of
income during that two years plus we
started at 125 and ended up at 180.
excellent excellent what do y'all do for
a living
I'm a licensed professional counselor
and I'm an engineer in oil and gas oh
yeah okay so who got the big bump
during this time um I got a new job and
he got several promotions they're both
of you then okay that's the way it works
isn't it all right good good so what
kind of debt was 145 000. everything the
first thing we paid off was my wedding
ring
then we had credit cards student loan
cars
um we have a nine month old baby so she
bumped that up for us in June so good
she's not gonna get repoed now all right
so the uh wow y'all were like normal
yeah how long you been married
um almost almost three years we got
married uh May uh 2020 right in the
height of the oh wow oh yeah you did
yeah you did yeah we actually eloped
um in May of 2020
um and then where did you go where
humans were running around at that time
we just went to a lake near us with our
parents
but they didn't weren't any humans it's
good yeah I like that we went in ahead
and had our big party too and we would
not advise that if you're already
married just go be married don't get
twenty thousand dollars more of debt oh
there you go oh you can add that for
like the reception that you did later
yes so not long after that
we look up and you say we're going to do
something different we're gonna do this
Ramsey thing what did you do what
happens what happened yeah we got home
from our extravagant wedding in our
extravagant honeymoon
um you know because we're from Texas
everything's bigger in Texas and uh we
looked at our event count said
well we uh all our money's gone now we
spin it all on our wedding and our
honeymoon so we decided like what are we
gonna do and she had been kind of
nudging me about this Ramsey thing I was
like oh I don't need Dave Ramsey I'm not
broke I'm an engineer at a little gas
and so then like one late night I was
like trying to
do the budge in my head kind of figure
it out so then I was like you know I'm
Google's Dave Ramsey and I was like okay
like this makes sense like this math
adds up one plus one equals two and so
after that we kind of just took off
running
sort of sort of yeah we started Davis we
were limping limping along yeah we
started Davis and then we got a
financial coach uh Jim Parker shout out
to her she was awesome she got us
through this thing
um right after covet and everything she
goes all the way through and
and then we just kind of we had a baby
and that was just like that was the last
motivation that made us go hey that we
we got to do this like we gotta do this
for her yeah once the baby comes it
turns it up yeah it got real now it got
real yeah
our goal was we want to be done with
baby step two before she takes her first
step oh that's good well I like it so
you guys I mean looking at the numbers
y'all did it y'all did it quick I mean I
know you had a great income but you
didn't you really felt the sacrifice so
what was like the biggest things that
you guys cut that you feel like really
helped and then what were things that
you added in that you were like oh yeah
that everyone needs to do this to help
them get out of debt uh she made me sell
my boat
in return I sold my car whoa
stole some stuff yeah yeah I was a 1099
employee when we started this and Evan
was very worried about what taxes was
going to look like everyone needs
someone responsible in your life because
I was like it's fine but we saved and
saved and saved because we were scared
of what income tax was going to look
like and when that time came we actually
only ended up paying a little bit and we
had 8 500 left over and we found a cream
puff car
um a 2007
Ford Edge sport for 85 000 8 500 yeah 8
500 yes I feel better already and uh so
uh what did your sell for
um we actually ended up having to pay
um about 1800. but what did it sell for
total what was the total price oh it was
22. 22 000 of the 145. what'd the boats
sell for uh 12-5 okay what kind of boat
it was a bass boat okay all right so
you'll get anything you want now later
yeah oh yeah I promise it was the deal I
get a Suburban he gets a boat here we go
awesome with cash yeah I like it I like
it okay so what was the hardest part
because you guys had a baby in the
middle of all this so what would you say
though was like oh that was a tough that
was a tough thing whether it was a
sacrifice or obviously having a baby
it's like wow that's a that's a lot in
the middle of this I I think for us it
was like oh we're young we should be
having fun we should be going and seeing
the world
um but now it's like now that we look
back and I was like wow we would have
just done stupid things so I wouldn't
solve the world and so instead we just
now we're old we can appreciate the
world there you go yay live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else we also um did Rome dog sitting
so for me this was the hardest part is
Evan went to go see his family the
weekend that we were doing Christmas
Rover and I was pregnant and I had 23
dogs in our house by myself and I was
pregnant so he was only gone one night
but he will never get to live that I
don't even want to think about it
for the six thousand dollars in a week
it was worth it six thousand dollars
okay it was worth the sacrifice oh Rover
yeah
Rover come over oh my gosh wow wow well
done you guys yeah that's a hard 24
hours though it was yeah that's that's
ridiculous for motherhood you do that
prepared me for mother that's right yeah
and then some Wow way to go all right
now when your friends are looking at you
and they thought you were crazy how'd
you keep going
uh not number one
um for sure like when we were at the
height of all our money
um he was there when we were at the
bottom in the valley he was there and
now that we're back we're not on top of
the mountain yet but we're working back
to the top of the mountain and he's
right here with us I think um when
you're a good Steward of the money God
gives you he gives you more money to be
a good Steward of that's what the Bible
says yeah when you're faithful in the
little things you'll be given more to
manage yeah yeah very well done good for
you very good congratulations
yeah that's that's impressive very
impressive who was who was cheering you
on from the sidelines
um so I grew up with the Dave ramsey-ish
life my parents are going to watch this
and be ashamed of themselves but we did
we did envelopes on and off my whole
life so I knew what it was I just didn't
know like is it really that sustainable
um so our parents have been both huge
supporters Jen Parker our financial
coach she she whipped us into shape we
actually got her because I was like
let's buy a house Nevin was like that's
not what we're doing right now I was
like but lots of people do it like it's
fine
um so that's so great and then we
actually our fight our friend Hallie
who's here with us
um it was great to have someone on this
journey with us who understood when we
said
we can't that's not in the budget we
can't do that and then she would say the
same thing you know like I can't do that
it's not in my budget hey we got the
live and give bundle for you that's the
baby steps Millionaire's book you're on
your way to being baby steps for
millionaires a Total Money Makeover book
and a Financial Peace University
membership so you can use them or give
them away they're there for you thanks
for making the trip and uh you brought
little Eliza with you and she is a happy
kid yeah we've been laughing at her
she's laughing at everything over here
she's great and how old is Eliza she's
almost 10 months all right she's fun and
she's gonna love the microphone I like
it that's good all right Evan Laurie and
Eliza Alonzo your life has been changed
your family tree has changed kiddo and
you don't even know it 145 000 paid off
in 27 months count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
I love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Corinthians 16 13 be on your guard stand
firm in the faith be courageous be
strong
Maya Angelou said without courage we
cannot practice any other virtue with
consistency we can't be kind
true merciful generous or honest
very good like it retro Cruz Ramsay
personality is my co-host today John is
with us in Dallas Texas hey John welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey y'all thanks for having me sure
what's up
I'm just going to figure out how much
house my wife and I can afford if we
plan on paying cash
wow good for you well obviously it's
going to be limited about how much cash
you have then so let's start with that
what's the game plan
um well we have in uh checking and
savings accounts we have about 500 000
and then in brokerage accounts and other
investment accounts we have about 2
million
um and then we have a rental property uh
as well that's about 400 000 that's paid
uh paid off so I guess ultimately what
we're trying to figure out is how much
can we afford without jeopardizing our
future
well obviously you've done a lot of
wonderful things congratulations
uh you know three million dollar net
worth how old are you
I'm 29 and my wife is 26. wow where'd
all this money come from
uh mostly uh unfortunately when my my
wife's mother passed away a large chunk
of it was an inheritance so that's where
the majority of that came from okay all
right well I'm sorry for your loss
um and so you know you've got this
responsibility to be uh honoring of that
Legacy right that's why you're asking a
good wise question like you're asking
okay so um
a rule of thumb in general as we deal
with wealthy people and you are now
officially in that category
um
the larger your net worth the smaller
the percentage of your net worth would
be in your personal residence
let me give you an extreme example let's
say you had a hundred million dollar net
worth
if you bought a five million dollar
house it would only be five percent
right
but if you had a 10 million dollar net
worth and you bought a five million
dollar house would be 50 percent
so you wouldn't do you wouldn't do that
okay as an example so the the larger
your net worth the smaller it should be
so if you have a small net worth like
much smaller than yours like say you had
a a one million dollar net worth and if
you wouldn't even want fifty percent in
that
if you could keep from it okay it's not
the end of the world but
um so we don't want to go north of 50 I
can't think of a situation where I would
go north of 50 in your personal
residence
um and so you know that that limited so
that's that that gives us a number to
start with say a million and a half okay
then I start scaling back from that
because your personal residence while it
does go up in value does not create an
income
the other Investments create income and
the more you move from The Brokerage
that's invested in mutual funds into the
house that every dollar of that becomes
dormant when you move it into the house
or virtually dormant you see what I'm
saying
yes sir and and so I don't I don't want
to put you in a 200 000 house either uh
but somewhere south of a million million
range what were you all thinking
um well it you know somewhere around
there we're also in the middle of a of a
life decision
um uh the state that we're originally
from uh is a lot more expensive than
Texas and family is there and with my
wife just graduating we're trying to
figure out
um whether we want to be here or or
there so you know if we were to go back
there
um for what we're trying to look for I
would imagine it would be in the million
dollar range and then you know in Texas
um something comparable probably between
700 to 800 000 is is my rough guess yeah
that sounds fair I don't think any of
those are going to fall in the dumb
category what's your household income
going to be with her graduating
uh with her graduating it could be
anywhere from 250 to 300 000 a year
depending on the the starting salary
that she gets okay all right
uh wow what does she do what is she
gonna be doing um physician assistant
okay that's great well you guys are in a
great position John which is which is
awesome and you know the hard thing is
too comparing real estate from Dallas to
wherever else you're comparing where is
it California New York Colorado Okay
um the math still doesn't change right
so like the percentage I just don't want
you guys think justifying well this is a
more expensive area so we we have to be
we have to spend more for some reason
right and you start justifying a crazy
purchase I don't think you're going to
but always just be aware of that because
it can be easy just to say well what we
what the house we would have had in
Dallas if we have that here it's going
to cost this much and you just kind of
make it this this equal thing where it's
not right you have to plug in that math
so just be wary of that when you guys
are shopping if you guys choose to go to
Colorado don't justify well these are
just more higher prices so let's go a
million and a half right and do
something that you regret yeah I think
you set your budget and then you work
into that but the the 700 to million
none of those numbers concern me I think
they're all fine
okay and I kind of backed into that you
were with me as I was discussing it with
myself okay
okay you heard me walk through that
right
yes sir and so the idea being then that
you've got a couple of million dollars
minimum that's going to be generating
income
while you're living a million dollar or
less house and you're going to have no
payments anywhere in your world ever
you have to swear to that and and you
have a you know 250 300 000 income and
so now you're in you're fully funding
401ks and Roth IRAs so you're going to
build several million tens of millions
of well dollars of wealth with your
income aside from this inheritance
uh within a decade or two
okay if you'll just if you'll just stay
in control here and whatever you do you
pay cash for it and uh you know uh and
you know and have make sure that you're
allocating some percentage of your life
to enjoy some of this money to be
generous with some of this money and
always to be investing some of this
money you need to be doing all three all
the time most of us struggle with
leaning too heavily on one of those or
the other and
um I I don't think you're going to but
just watch for that just always be we
even teach children this parents when
they're teaching their children teach
them to to enjoy the money that's wise
spending and buy some things that are
nice you have three million dollars
that's okay uh have a decent trip or two
here or there you need to do that you
got three million dollars you make 300
000 a year that's okay but be
outrageously generous
it's the most fun you'll ever have with
money look for generosity opportunities
and grow that muscle and then be
steadily regularly consistently month in
and month out automatic draft from your
checking account automatic draft out of
your uh paycheck going into your 401k be
an investor be doing all of that you're
going to be just fine man they're really
yeah it's well done John I mean that's
that's incredible and just the diligence
too of asking these questions I think is
so so encouraging so I'm excited for you
guys and I always ask myself too since
some of this came from you know Grandma
or Mom uh you know what is honoring
their legacy what's honoring their
memory with this money
and so if I you know am I doing
something that helps me kind of check
myself if I'm being a little childish or
irresponsible or out of control or
something is I you know I can just is
that making Mom in heaven smile when I
do this with the money and uh you know
you don't want like be guilt-tripping
yourself that's not what I'm talking
about but it just kind of checks you and
says okay that's out of control but if
you bought a nice car would she be
smiling that was reasonable yeah she
would be especially for our grandkids
running around in it you know that kind
of stuff yeah
well I think it's interesting though
because people that work the baby steps
a lot of the time we hear oh my gosh we
got on baby step seven where they are
and it's hard for them to spend it's
hard for them to go back to that muscle
of enjoying their money
um I feel like that's a that's a
consistent call we get or even through
baby steps four through six and when
people kind of get out of that intense
phase of the part that yeah you're
you're good like this is the reason you
did stuff so honestly even allocating
and forcing yourself to do the things
that are uncomfortable so whether that's
safe that's whether that's spending have
an amount of money that you're like okay
we have to practice spending like we for
some people that's really hard enjoying
it yeah and then for some people it's
saving and it's like having this number
that even if it's not your natural bent
you still do it over and over and over
again so putting it down on paper and
being intentional with it is always
really helpful good stuff good stuff
well done
well that about puts this particular
hour in the books Rachel good show today
this hour in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]